les joueurs de l'équipe de football de
la polyvalente de charlesbourg célèbre
une victoire lors plus important de la
saison en demi finale parmi eux raphaël
le numéro 55 savoure chaque instant est
en s'aimant parce que cette victoire
c'est aussi la sienne avant je me suis
tout le temps je faisais rien mais là je
fais quelque chose je 5g sert à quelque
chose
dany félicite son fils autiste pour la
première fois de sa vie à 14 ans raphaël
pratiquer un sport comme les autres
garçons et filles c'est un gaillard
n'est une même fragile à vous et aux
autres santé s à son tour bhl du spectre
de l'autisme là beaucoup remué quand
j'étais plus jeune je lis révéler
certaines personnes clés que je
considérais digne de confiance
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient le team
trahissent en fait non pas à tout le
monde en riant la rumeur s'est propagée
tout le monde rien de moins au look 6
slots et à retarder se réfère accepte de
se livrer ainsi aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'il est sorti de cette solitude qui
affligent trop souvent des jeunes comme
du diagnostic de dépression depuis juin
et tout l'été quand commencer l'année
scolaire un appel au travail qui a dit
maman fait quelque chose commence le
football comme dans 2 nous on voyait le
potentiel 25 amis dans l'école avec lui
qui allait les pros les murs qu'ils lui
ont donc fait une place avec ses forces
et ses faiblesses
durant les matchs il lui arrive souvent
de se mettre à l'écart seul assis au
banc mais toujours prêt à sauter sur le
terrain
j'ai jamais été en contact les personnes
qui ont des trucs du spectateur
je n'ai traité comme n'importe quelle
heure de mes joueurs en état respectueux
de ses limites et des appâts performer à
formule prépayée
maintenant s'ils rentrent une balade au
fil de la saison va faire c'est dévoiler
petit à petit à ses coéquipiers il est
devenu un joueur régulier avec beaucoup
d'empathie
chaque fois qu'un coéquipier se blesse
il est le premier à vouloir le
réconforter ça fait partie de son adn
elle avait de la demi-finale à la
demande de raphaël le responsable du
programme de football à charlesbourg qui
est aussi éducateur spécialisé a pris la
parole devant tout le groupe pour
expliquer ce qu'est le différend je
voulais pour expliquer à faire je vais
expliquer la différence
j'ai réellement été émues de voir
certains joueurs prendre la parole puis
normaliser la situation normalisée le
fait qu' on a tout des différences mais
on est une équipe on est une famille la
fin ne veut déplaire à personne
lorsque l'entraîneur de l'équipe
perdante du souhaite bonne chance en
finale et qu'ils répondent vous aussi
son lapsus le vire à l'envers
mais lorsque j'ai fais s'adressait à
tous les jeunes autistes comme lui
son message est sans équivoque toutes
les personnes qui sont actifs stp
justement à sortir à le dévoiler
vous savez pour les belles choses qui
peuvent pas aussi juste la situation
manche je suis vraiment content ça fait
longtemps que j'ai plus de plaisir comme
ça et c'était palliser sortez allez les
rôles isolé ou sans saigner
[Applaudissements]
françois poirier du canada à saint
joseph de bouche